Thanks for doing that. So now remember we're trying to decide if me singing a
song that I wrote about hypothesis testing is going to increase your engagement
in learning. In the last example, confidence intervals were really great when
we were trying to estimate the actually population parameters. For example the
engagement from our example before. In this case, the dependant variable, so
the engagements ratio, makes sense by itself, we understand what that means.
The number of minutes students spend watching the course to the total amount of
minutes that are available. But in this case, your self-reported measures of
engagment and learning aren't as well defined. And there subject to your
individual perceptions of what good, engagement and learning are. Obviously
higher numbers, like nines and tens are better, but what does it really mean if
you report your engagement as seven. In this case we don't care as much what
the actually between one and ten will be. We just want to see if the
intervention or the song possibly has an effect.